the woman accusing NFL superstar Antonio
Brown of sexual assault
plans to meet with league officials
later today that's according to the
Associated Press Brittany Taylor used to
be Browns personal trainer she filed a
lawsuit last week claiming that he raped
her she'll meet with the NFL on the day
after Brown scored his first touchdown
for the New England Patriots he played
yesterday our national correspondent
tarika Duncan is now with us with more
on this story so Jericka what's the
significance of today's meeting
well good morning Gail this meeting will
be a part of the NFL's investigation
into Taylor's claims so far no criminal
charges have been filed against Brown
but it is possible the league could
place him on the commissioners exempt
list during its investigation which
would make him ineligible to play Brady
from the gun fires he's got brown on the
New England Patriots first drive against
the Miami Dolphins Sunday all eyes were
on Antonio Brown taking the field in his
debut game with his new team the wide
receiver caught four passes including
one for a touchdown but off the field
Brown is facing serious allegations
Brittany Taylor who accused him of
sexual assault will meet with NFL
officials today investigators will
reportedly ask her if she has any
evidence beyond what's presented in her
lawsuit against Brown Taylor had cited
three separate incidents since 2017 in
which she says Brown assaulted her
including an allegation of rape Brown
has denied any wrongdoing and has
threatened to countersue the miami-dade
County State Attorney's Office says it
has no record of a police investigation
regarding the allegations Brown left
Sunday's game without taking questions
from reporters coach Bill Belichick and
other players focused only on Browns
performance on the field a lot of things
we can work on but it's good to have him
out there he continues to be who we
expect them to be and that's a great
wall receiver